you already know who it is it's your
favorite score's favorite score and this
video right here is for the nine to
fivers don't know [ __ ] about meta the
ones who don't know [ __ ] about nothing
who just come home to play the game and
play realistic who better to do it with
than me let's get right to it jog right
down not even using the turbo oh slid
this right through the middle that's a
steamer the only way to beat these
little ass bed bugs they strongly should
be last five tens he trying to get lower
than me but he can't tweet cross kick
off step back back the [ __ ] up bro
blinkers that's draws don't just stand
there with your thumbnail ass go be
useful make a play come on now you see
how i throw this behind my head off the
hook that's draws man just look how i
move different from the pack come on now
tween behind the back snatch that oozy
back goldfish by now in transition i
either know it's one of two things is
either one a bucket two a diamond my man
was down bad so i had to toss him a dime
come on he didn't even know he was
getting that blessed them at a young age
i was taught never play with your fool
you get in trouble for things like that
there's people out there starving to
need that but you know one thing i'ma do
i'ma stalk his ass like i'm randy orton
in 2009 going for that punt double tween
one tweet get off my back i ain't
playing no games hey stretcher i'm done
come on ruff
staying low staying slow and most of all
staying pro i'm taking him from the east
to the west he's literally changing time
zones while he's in his bedroom guarding
me so i hope i never have to introduce
myself again because